would you watch a porn with the hottest  girl from your high school if the dude  in it was your dad  a bunch of porn with the hottest girl  from your high school  listen you know there's always that one  girl you remember in high school yeah  but  but she's  we're in the magical world she's not a  drug addict she still looks like she  looks but she's not a high school girl  it's the perfect scene for you to watch  i mean here's the thing that you get  that here's the thing my dad  treated his house like a locker room  like he was just ass naked all the time  like i've i've seen a lot of my dad and  i just haven't asked for it  um so it wouldn't shock me that much but  i i don't particularly  care to watch  any girl from high school have sex  yeah  a few of them do only fans now though so  i can just pay for it